Wir haben besonders unsere Kategorie,
sie heißt Fragenlotterie und die
grünen sind sehr, sehr nette Fragen
mit vielen Komplimenten darin und die
Nassen, ich denke, Sie können sich vorstellen, ist ein
bisschen verrückt, es ist ein bisschen
provozierend, okay, fangen wir mit
a an  rot Okay ich schaue nicht einmal nach sagen wir mal
was ist das oh du hast ein
grünes also kannst du es öffnen und die
Frage lesen wenn dir gefällt was ich gar nicht
hast du hast eine bemerkenswerte karriere du warst
ein sportstar model  Und jetzt, Nektar, wie
oft stehst du vor dem Memo
und sagst dir, ja, heiße Sachen, ich stehe nicht hier und mache das, an dem
Tag, an dem ich es tue
, ist das ein
trauriger Tag  Tage, an denen du sagst, oh, ich kann es nicht
glauben, aber das ist wahr, es ist nicht das,
was sie in dieser Richtung denken,
denn du weißt, was Erfolg ist, ist eine
vorübergehende Sache, du weißt, dass es so ist, als ob das, was
nach oben geht, nach unten kommt und du du selbst sein
musst  müssen sich bewusst sein, dass es nicht in
Ihrer Kontrolle liegt, also y  Du solltest es sein,
du musst es zu schätzen wissen, dass die Leute
deine Filme sehen wollen, aber du weißt,
dass das nicht immer der Fall ist, du weißt, dass
manchmal der Geschmack einfach
nicht mehr gut schmeckt, also bin
ich dankbarer  weil
ich in einem Job bin, der ein wenig
unvorhersehbar ist okay nächste Frage du kannst dir
eine aussuchen da gibt es viel
Geld auszugeben das ist nicht meine Frage also sei bitte
nett zu mir du machst nur Actionfilme
willst du nicht  Mache andere Filme wie
Schauspielen in einem Drama. Ich habe kürzlich einen Film
namens Hummingbird gemacht, dieser mit einem
sehr, sehr berühmten Schriftsteller
in Großbritannien, sein Name ist Steven Knight
ersten Film und
wir haben ihn letztes Jahr in London gedreht und ich bin
wirklich sehr stolz darauf, es ist
etwas, das viele Emotionen hat
, die ich nie ausdrücken kann,
es ist definitiv ein Schritt in eine Richtung
, die ich gesucht habe  mach ok gut
luc  k für die letzte Frage
vielleicht Rhett erstaunlich wir wollen alle
du bist der beliebteste Actionstar
unserer Zeit wie spektakulär ist der ganze Tag
mit Jason Statham wie spektakulär
ist der Alltag überhaupt nicht so spektakulär
es ist wie bei jedem anderen, weißt du
, ja ich  neige dazu, alle meine Freunde
von dir fernzuhalten, seit ich
am selben Ort aufgewachsen bin und sich nichts
geändert hat
Ich arbeite die
ganze Zeit
, das ist das einzige, alles andere
scheint gleich zu sein, okay, vielen Dank,
okay,
du